what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about a topic that i see
often in the mano sphere but before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos if you have
watched
three or more of my videos and you have
not subscribed look at me
we got beef
if you've watched three of my videos hit
that subscribe button right now
right now
okay
today i'm going to be talking about sex
i hear
often
on
every manosphere podcast
sex is an equal value exchange because
both parties like get to have sex
whatever
i disagree
and let me tell you why
everyone in the manosphere will agree
that a woman loses value
every person that she has sex with
while a man
gains value
with every woman
that he has sex with
i would think that there would be some
cap like at some point it just gets
weird
like four digits
weird but whatever you know
so if that's the case then how is it an
equal value exchange
when you are quite literally
transferring
value
i rest my case um
anyways pearl thoughts let me know in
the comments what you think don't forget
to subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time